mitu inceste si en sport quel rôle
jouent les motions ça c'est la grosse
question
l'émotion peut être un moyen
effectivement de passer le mur du
silence est d'attirer l'attention sur
des phénomènes comme les violences
sexuelles qui sont souvent cachés ou
ignorer l'émotion est évidemment très
prisé par les médias parce que ça met de
l'animation ça peut relancer le
conducteur d'une émission ou permettre
d'animer le contenu des chaînes
d'information en continu le souci auquel
on est confronté aujourd'hui c'est que
l'émotion et en particulier les motions
des victimes va clore le débat
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où
une émotion s'exprime on considère que
la sphère est jugé et qu'il n'ya plus à
discuter avec ce que ce qu'on appelle le
tribunal médiatique on a des personnes
qui par le simple fait d'avoir été
accusé
se voient sanctionnés on a eu le cas de
comédiens qui sont accusés d'avoir
commis des agressions sexuelles et dont
on va des programmes et des films
ce faisant entre parenthèses on
sanctionne aussi tous ceux qui
travaillent dans le film mais pas
uniquement
le comédien ou le réalisateur il faut
toujours prévoir un espace où on puisse
confronter mettre en débat mettre en
discussion
sinon on va aboutir à des erreurs
judiciaires ou des erreurs de jugement
et on va pénaliser des personnes qui ne
mérite peut-être pas un châtiment aussi
cruel
[Musique]